am donnerstag beim fliegerhorst
hinterstoisser in zeltweg einer der
ersten bundesheer piloten kommt zu
besuch
1958 hat er hier in zeltweg seinen flug
grundausbildung absolviert von 1960 an
ist er sie geflogen die ersten
düsenflugzeuge des bundesheeres von der
dh 115 empire bis zu support 29 auch
liebevoll tonne genannt
1965 wechselte er zur aua wo er die
nächsten 33 jahre als kapitän und flug
ausbilder tätig sein wird wir reden hier
von adolf theisinger der mit rund 20.800
flugstunden umgerechnet 2,3 jahre seines
lebens in der luft verbracht hat
oberstleutnant jörg sandhofer selbst
ehemaliger eurofighter pilot holt zu
ehren des besuches einen taifun aus dem
hangar den fachgesprächen über die
entwicklungen in der fliegerei steht nun
nichts mehr im weg
kennedy viel strick nichts und der
eurofighter kann wirklich sehr lange in
der luft bleiben statt einer stunde
wurde neben traktorist fahrstunde tränen
instrumentenflug straßen friwo mal hier
reduziert und genau das ist am traten
nicht für das anders gewesen ja das hat
gekommen noch mehr das würde ich
wirklich gerne wenn ich mit 350 liter im
sommer zum hof mit capoeira und und so
genannter unterschied zu allen anderen
pfleger wo sie bis jetzt geflogen bin am
eurofighter brauchst du um das nicht
kümmern sich selber und flaps wird meine
kritik kommt
macht alle selbstständig du gibst steuer
impulse den flieger was der pfleger mit
den mit den rother macht weißt du nicht
dass er macht es das umsetzen
plötzlich werden die beiden stars beim
fachsimpeln gestört zwei eurofighter
setzen zur landung an
deshalb ist es amtlich
es ist ein fest
danach geht es für ein wiedersehen uns
flieger museum dort trifft adolf
theisinger auf sein arbeitsgerät von
anno dazumal die vampires und die tonne
hartmann nicht gewollt die die wollten
die piloten wäre das die forscher mit
die sollte piloten sollten erscheinung
vor baustellen hat haben wir vergessen
gar nicht
überschauen schleudersitz und war man
noch nie falsche hand reichen gahan hat
dann hat man das engagement bleibt mein
flieger und wann mein flieger bleibt der
flieger kommt es heute ist philosophie
aber ich das wirklich war jemand ist
diese einstellungen pilot ohne forschung
gesprungen bin dann verlassen können für
je schneller das war nur so die idee das
waren nicht wirklich gedacht kann man
natürlich die versteckten auch so leicht
mit dem schleudersitz retten das waren
14 g14 falsch wäre das wort und das war
nicht abgebrannt sondern das pakete die
nur gezündet das heißt man oder antritt
gerückt und die allermeisten die fäden
ausgesandt hat neu grad verletzungen
dadurch freunde aber nicht sauber
prinzessin ist nicht aufregend mit
amerika markt vorgewagt war aus dem wald
ratsam druck dass an dem später werden
noch einmal nimmt adolf heusinger im
cockpit platz
vertraut vertrauen
es geht nicht weg des gesichts der
sperre war wichtig
naja und schneider sitzt da
inzwischen die vier
sängerinnen
es ist mit stoff bezogen war über 26
jahren verpasst das tor
[Musik]
dies ist zur not werden von den raum
dass khan erinnern
[Musik]
da steht
brenzlig
zurückversetzt in die zeit der
bundesheer fliegerei in den 1960 er
jahren blickt adolf heusinger mit freude
und ohne wehmut zurück es war seine zeit
hatte in folgen zügen genossen
[Musik]